physically you feel good and you feel
like yeah I mean I've everything's good
I mean there are little things that
happen as you get older it's like I feel
like when I go to the airport now it's
like seems like millenials will just
kind of like lay anywhere in an airport
and I was thinking like gosh I mean I
just remember like getting told to like
sit up straight in my chair and it's
like you'll see Millennials at the
airport and they're just sprawled out
where it looks like a Civil War
battlefield I want to go up are you are
you okay yeah no they're very they're
very cool just chilling you know like
just lying down at like the lay across
like six seats or the or the everyday
like you might think that if you were at
the airport and there were no chairs but
I mean there'll be open chairs but
they'll they won't sit like you or I
might just sit like this yeah they'll be
like this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I mean this and imagine this being like
a walkway yeah yeah but anyhow I mean no
I've noticed that yeah you see there's a
generation that they're kind of like
gelatinous they just they just to
collapse into anything and they're
perfectly happy and I say if you can't
beat them join them I want to start
doing a big thing also if you like can't
ever find a plug for your phone like
they'll find a plug in like the end of a
person's cane or like
you